hello we're here to have a good time eh
we're getting invited to a party
[Music]
okay just let that go what's your excuse
though
maybe he just doesn't like you no more
words are definitely better than nothing
nothing recognizing quality acting
performances but here's the thing the
art of filmmaking is not a contest
plenty of quality work can coexist
together without crowding each other out
so I just want to take a moment to
recognize some of my favorite
performances from last year because
there's so much fantastic work being
done that just choosing a few to win a
few Awards doesn't really do it justice
in that spirit this also isn't a ranked
list and it's certainly not meant to be
definitive these are just a few
performances that really resonated with
me that didn't take home a little gold
man this video is sponsored by Henson
shaving get yours today using the link
in the description I can't really
honestly say that Cate blanchett's work
as Lydia tar and tar has been overlooked
but I haven't seen a lot of people
really dive into what is so great about
this performance there are those
performances where actors just step into
a role and fill it out in a believable
way and this requires talent and is
often what's called for but then there
are those roles where it feels like an
actor does the work to really build
something completely new what Blanchette
is doing here with tar feels to me like
what someone like Marlon Brando or Orson
Welles used to do with some of their
characters she's crafting and imposing
figure from the ground up how she talks
walks holds herself and gestures all
help to construct the essence of Lydia
tar but there's something else
underneath that which I think is even
more impressive and that's the way
Blanchette plays tar's hypocrisy and
performative nature schopenha measured a
man's intelligence against his
sensitivity to noise
didn't he once also throw a woman down a
flight of stairs who later sued him yes
that was unclear that this private and
personal failing at all relevant to his
work
[Laughter]
film slowly unfolds for the audience the
way in which this character is abusing
her power but what amazes me here in the
way that Blanchette plays it is that
we're never really sure how aware and
conscious tar is of her own abuses of
power there are many moments where she
is being hypocritical or manipulative
while performing innocence and virtue to
the people around her but I feel like it
goes a layer deeper where there are
moments where tar also seems to be
performing this plausible deniability
and false sense of virtue to herself I
mean
as a practical matter I mean this would
normally fall to you but given how much
is going to be asked of you of the
Mahler I I wanted to be at all bothered
if we were to hold auditions
she seems engaged in a heavy kind of
self-deception here yet we never get a
real explicit glimpse into what tar is
thinking so all this has to be played in
subtext and Blanchette pulls it off
masterfully
now let's go in a completely different
direction and I want to talk about
performances that aren't necessarily all
that dramatically weighty but which just
look and feel like they were a blast for
the actors to perform first up in this
subcategory is Daniel Craig in Glass
Onion in my opinion he's easily the best
part of this movie no no nothing I just
I I just thought maybe there was a prize
also
I
an iPad or like
okay fine yeah no no the winner gets an
iPad he's playing this role so
effortlessly and casually it's almost so
casual that I'm a little suspicious that
things might have been too easy for both
Benoit Blanc and Daniel Craig I have
occasionally put on the dog in my life
but there's this
this is stretch of my straw taking
abilities his performance in the first
movie was great but I think his
performance here is really the only
thing that's actually improved from the
first film to this sequel performances
like this can benefit from a lack of
self-seriousness there are times when a
little camp and playful energy just
comes through the screen in a way that
elevates the performance the actor being
relaxed and feeling relaxed is conveyed
somehow through the performance itself
it's maybe a subtle difference here but
I'm talking about the difference between
a performance that is fun to watch
because the character is funny and a
performance that is fun to watch because
the performance is funny sometimes just
the way an actor embodies the character
and moves through the world of the film
is fun to watch on its own
eight
similarly fun but much more unhinged is
Mia Goss performance as Pearl in Pearl
this character has a terrifying energy
that is defined by Goss performance she
gives one of last year's most intense
monologues in this film the wildest I
think I've seen since the lighthouse and
there's a completely Bonkers end credit
sequence that again is just relying on
Mia goth full sending this performance
in my best films of 2022 list I talked
about how I can appreciate a film that
commits to its concept or its bit
completely even if it doesn't quite pull
that off 100 I admire the commitment on
its own and that applies for me to
performances as well also unhinged and
last in the obviously having a blast
category is Toby Maguire in this bit
part from Babylon
Okay so
I'm open to the debate about whether or
not this sequence really adds much to
the movie as a whole but in my opinion
it's almost worth it just for this
character I'm still not convinced Damien
chiseled didn't pitched this role to
tobia as just do your best joker well I
thought you were just excited about the
idea
[Music]
he's really leaning into it here and
playing against type in a way that's
really fun if I was the kind of person
who wanted more Joker movies in the
world I would now be curious to see what
a Toby Maguire Joker movie might look
like I know just the guy to play him you
just build the movie around him he's
Sensational speaking of Babylon but
changing gears a little bit that whole
cast was fantastic Margot Robbie and
Brad Pitt both had predictably quality
performances and all the smaller parts
were really well cast but I want to give
a special shout out to Diego calva who I
had never seen in anything before this
but who I think really holds his own in
the midst of Stellar company here and it
made me excited about the possibility of
him catching a break from this and
getting to see more of him working at
this scale in the future
speaking of actors I now want to see
more of another performance that really
impressed me last year was Taylor
Russell in bones and all
when should I go along with him
um
something about him
I don't know
I think he was trying to help I
profoundly doubt that
just creepy I guess bones and all is
honestly one of these movies I still
have no idea what to actually feel about
but I honestly think it would be almost
totally unwatchable if it weren't
grounded in an incredibly vulnerable and
Human Performance which Taylor Russell
is completely nailing here brief side
note I think this also happens to be
Timothy chalamet's most interesting
performance since call me by your name I
have a nebula exclusive video where I
talk a little bit about the concept of
screen presence or at least my
interpretation of that and there were
two performances this year that really
had that sense of presence for me the
first is from Brian Tyree Henry in
Causeway did you serve
no
take Judy
something like that
just got back
how's it going
yeah
Brian really knows how to convey a
weight and depth in his work very
economically you can just feel the
characters underlying baggage and
turmoil without it feeling like he's
having to broadcast that to the audience
and forgive me for a brief tangent into
TV but his performance in Causeway
wasn't even his best work of 2022 both
of the final seasons of Atlanta came out
last year and his work as Alfred in
Nashville is also incredible and has a
lot of the same characteristics the
other performance for me that had an
immediate sense of screen presence was
Daniel kaluya as OJ and nope that's big
how big
would it look like
it was fast I know a lot of people felt
kind of underwhelmed by this performance
but I think it was great it's just more
restrained and understated than I think
we've maybe seen from colluya recently
and also I want to say can we just
admire the range that this guy has he
went from this kind of power and
confidence we in the Black Panther Party
don't believe in no coaches said
revolutionary culture what we mean my
dad is the coaches that will free you to
almost the opposite in this
um
I think my sister's gonna be here in a
minute
I said we are animal Wranglers in
back-to-back performances and as a
viewer I never for a moment doubted the
authenticity of either next up we have
Paul Moscow and after sun this is one of
the two performances I would have picked
out of the nominees for best actor this
year alongside Colin Farrell's work in
banshees but I want to highlight Moscow
specifically because this performance
really hits on that subtlety that I
really love that I talked about in my
subtle performance video I'm going to
have my baby soon congratulations yeah a
few years ago I thought I would be at
least four days before all that but
I can't see myself before to be honest
surprised immediately
there's one scene of big emotion here
but it's actually even played away from
camera so most of what we get is just
these subtle repressed emotions in the
character as he's trying to hide how he
actually feels from his daughter who
he's on vacation with he also manages to
stay right on this nice Edge between not
shying away from the character's flaws
and also making sure the character stays
sympathetic which I think is very
important to the overall Arc of the film
and without that finely balanced
performance the movie's ending wouldn't
really work I already mentioned Colin
Farrell's performance and banshees that
whole cast was great all the major
players got Oscar Noms but the
performance in here that stood out to me
the most especially on repeat viewings
was Carrie condon's she's kind of
playing the straight man against all the
men in the film and she pulls us off
really well while also still being
hilarious it was the 18th century anyway
Mozart
not 17th
but there's another layer which is kind
of how much she's communicating the
emotional Arc of this character through
the subtext in her performance here
which I think is such an important
counterweight to what's going on in the
rest of the story that the movie would
really fall apart and not work as well
if it weren't for the quality of this
performance comedic performances don't
usually get as much recognition
especially from the Academy Awards but
there were two that stood out to me from
the excellent ensemble cast of triangle
of sadness that I want to highlight in
their cleaning lady here captain
okay
the first is Dolly De Leon's Performance
as the cleaning lady turned boss lady in
the movie's third act she plays this
role with such a sharp dead pan that
never flinches for a moment and I think
she's easily the best part of the
movie's third chapter and I also want to
mention Harris Dickinson as Carl what
was the price of that one this one is 28
000 Euros
who nails that sort of mopey sad boy
privileged nice guy energy in a way that
captures the kind of hilarious
simultaneous sense of victimhood and
entitlement perfectly without turning
him entirely into an unsympathetic
caricature just the body language of his
performance I find really funny
throughout this film and as a grand
finale I want to mention the entire cast
of The Irish film The Quiet girl which
technically came out last year but I
didn't get the chance to see until
recently every performance in this movie
is in my opinion Flawless every subtle
emotional beat is hit perfectly this
movie has such a gentle loving
Melancholy energy that is truly rare and
it's light on dialogue so there's a lot
of room here for the Fantastic
performances to shine I'm sneaking a
mention into this video because the
performances are amazing but it's also
still in the midst of its theatrical
release in the US and some other
countries and I wanted an excuse to Hype
up this fantastic film I think you
should go see it's by far my favorite
new release I've seen so far this year
shout out to everyone who is doing
fantastic work even in the corners of
film that don't really get many
accolades and what are your favorite
performances from last year that you
felt got overlooked I obviously don't
have time to watch or talk about
everything so let me know in the
comments what performances you love that
you felt were underrated
now let's talk about a different kind of
performance
shaving performance
there we go luckily for this ad read I
don't need to use gimmicky words like
ultimate shaving performance because I'm
in the very comfortable position of
promoting a product that in my opinion
is just better than the other options
there are three big reasons why for me
this razor from Henson shaving the al-13
is just better the first is
sustainability two billion disposable
razors end up in landfills every year
that's not including the plastic in the
packaging and the carbon emissions
involved in producing and delivering a
package of razors to you periodically
for the rest of your life this razor on
the other hand has no plastic in it
whatsoever and more importantly you buy
this once and it's going to last you a
lifetime There's an actual lifetime
warranty that comes with it but just
holding this thing I have no trouble
believing that this thing will actually
be round and functional longer than me
the only thing you'll have to replace
are the blades which brings me to the
next major benefit to pay for the blades
for this thing you're looking at
probably five dollars a year if you do
the math and add up the cost of this
versus a disposable razor or an electric
razor over even just two years of use
this ends up being like basically a
third the cost of disposable razors
after just two years much less an entire
lifetime's worth of use that brings me
to the last point which is the design of
this thing if you're like me you might
have tried typical safety razors before
this is definitely not that hence and
shaving before they were a shaving
company were an aerospace Manufacturing
Company the amount the blade sticks out
past the head of the razor is actually
less than the width of a hair the way
they designed these channels here in the
head makes rinsing the hair out of the
blade incredibly easy it's the easiest
razor to use that I've ever used
I'll say it it this razor performs
better than other razors
so if you want to get this thing click
the link in the description down below
and when you add it to your cart throw a
pack of 100 blades in there on me just
use the code thomasflight at checkout to
get that pack of 100 blades for free
thanks so much to Henson shaving for
making the first razor that I've ever
actually really liked and also for
sponsoring this video
[Music]